this is electromagnetic radiation you
can't see it but it's there in fact it's
everywhere but here's a more relatable
form this is the color cyan but more
accurately this is waves of
electromagnetic radiation oscillating at
about 616 trillion 856 billion 909
million 465 000 21 times per second as
they reach your eyes light receptive
cells translate the radiation into
electric signals which travel to your
brain and are generally perceived as the
color that we collectively refer to as
cyan if we strip away our interpretation
though the radiation scaled up about 100
000 times looks like this the color cyan
is waves of energy roughly 486nm
wide but what happens if that width
tightens
at 380 nanometers our perception changes
to this dark purple meanwhile if it
expands to a roomy 780 nanometers our
brains interpret the radiation as this
shade of dark red essentially as the
wavelength changes so too do the
properties so what happens if we change
the wavelength more dramatically like
tightening it by 100 times well now the
waves have much higher energy they're
much more powerful so much so that they
can actually pass through some less
dense materials like fabric or human
tissue but they aren't quite strong
enough to pass through denser materials
like metal or bone you can see where
this is going we refer to these
wavelengths as x-rays and use their
special properties to look inside bags
at airport security and inside humans at
the hospital
so what happens at the other end of the
spectrum what if instead of the width of
human dna the waves were the width of
humans well this is what we'd refer to
as an ultra high frequency radio wave
its comparatively enormous wavelength
allows it to travel over huge distances
pass through obstructions and even bend
around obstacles all useful properties
if you wanted to use electromagnetic
radiation to say communicate of course
in order to convey information using a
radio wave we'd need a way to manipulate
the radio wave that corresponds to the
desired information for this there are
options to start with there's the
strength of the wave we know that a blue
light for example can be weak or strong
but no matter if it's weak or strong
it's still blue and the fact that it's
blue means that it's still fundamentally
the same wavelength of electromagnetic
radiation the same principle applies up
the spectrum with radio waves they can
be powerful weak or anywhere in between
and still be the same wavelength in this
context we call that strength the
amplitude therefore we can transmit an
audio signal for example by modifying
that amplitude by a proportional amount
the receiver just needs to know how to
interpret those amplitude modulations
and translate them back to an audio
signal in the case of an am radio
station the radio receiver only focuses
on the radiation with a wavelength
1119 feet or 341 meters long for example
and it tracks the amplitude modulations
to output the audio signal that we end
up hearing amplitude modulation radio
communication has a number of useful
features it's exceptionally simple and
can work over huge distances but it does
tend to be highly susceptible to outside
interference that's a big reason why am
radio tends to be lower quality and a
big reason why it's not as useful a
technique for transmitting bigger chunks
of data of course the wavelength can
also be manipulated that means that we
can essentially do the same thing but
this time by ever so slightly modifying
the distance between waves in this
context we'd refer to this as the
frequency which is proportional to
wavelength but rather than being a
physical measure it's a temporal one how
many times the wave oscillates within a
second so by slightly modulating
frequency we can transmit the same audio
signal but since this method is less
susceptible to interference we can
generally get higher quality now
traditional radio works by encoding the
audio signal itself into radio waves
using amplitude or frequency modulation
but computers phones essentially
everything digital nowadays encodes its
data into binary code sequences of ones
and zeros this only makes communication
using electromagnetic radiation better
we could set it up so that when the
amplitude is high that corresponds to a
one well when it's low it corresponds to
a zero or rather when frequency is high
that's a one and when low that's a zero
this is simple and already more
efficient than encoding the analog audio
signal but it could be even more
efficient
that's because there's yet another wave
property that we can manipulate for
these purposes we can consider one full
cycle of a wave going up down and up
again one phase
but we can also consider this the wave
going down then up then down again one
phase as well
therefore we could assign this upward
phase to the binary digit one and this
one the downward phase to the binary
digit zero then we can transmit data
using a sequence of these different
phases the transmitter doesn't need one
phase to seamlessly go into the next so
it's an even faster even more efficient
way of encoding binary sequences into
electromagnetic radiation but here's
where things get really cool there can
be more than two phases we could divide
the cycle into one phase starting at the
midpoint going upward one starting at
the crest one starting at the midpoint
going downward and one starting at the
trough so with four distinct phases one
can correspond to the binary sequence 0
1 1 2 1 1 1 2 1 0 and 1 2 0 0. therefore
we can cram twice as much data into the
same signal but it doesn't stop there we
can even take this a step further and
have eight distinct phases so that we
can transmit every possible three-digit
sequence of ones and zeros thereby
tripling efficiency eight distinct
phases is typically the practical limit
for wireless data transmission it
becomes too tough to distinguish between
phases with anymore so the error rate is
too high however this is just
manipulating one property of the wave
and there are of course two others
this phase initially upward from the
midpoint could be broadcast at a high
amplitude or a low amplitude so we can
say that the low amplitude version of
this correlates to the binary sequence
zero zero zero zero well the high
amplitude version zero zero zero one by
adding two amplitude options to each of
the eight phases we get 16 total
transmission options meaning we have
enough to correlate to each of these 16
possible four digit combinations of
zeros and ones if we have an accurate
enough method of transmission we could
further increase the number of phase and
amplitude combinations to a total of 64
each corresponding to a six-digit binary
sequence in fact the newest wi-fi
standards have 1024
phase and amplitude combinations while
extremely accurate copper twisted cables
can deal with 32
768 combinations each corresponding to a
15 digit sequence constrained by the
accuracy of wireless communication your
cell phone meanwhile uses as few as 16
combinations in the case of some 3g
networks and as many as 1024 in the most
advanced 5g networks fundamentally
though this is how your cell phone gets
a lot of data out of a little slice of
the radio spectrum
of course transmitting data is only half
the battle something also needs to
receive it that something is of course a
cell site
now keep in mind that a cell phone is
essentially just a fancy walkie-talkie
it uses the exact same process just more
advanced in fact the earliest portable
phones car phones were just one step
removed from walkie talkies a telephone
company would set up a radio transmitter
in a city users would install a bulky
system in their car the system would
communicate with the transmitter just as
a walkie-talkie would and the tower
would then plug the signal into the
landline network put another way it was
just a city-wide version of cordless
landlines the only difference from
walkie-talkies was that these car phones
would have a dedicated channel for
outbound transmission and a dedicated
channel for inbound transmission so that
both sides could talk simultaneously
unlike with a walkie-talkie where one
needs to wait and push to talk since
only one channel is used these car
phones were fairly similar to today's
cell phones from a user experience
perspective but they were horribly
inefficient in their early days there
were only 32 available channels meaning
only 32 people in a city could use their
car phone simultaneously in addition if
one left the service area of that one
tower in their home city their car
phones wouldn't work
of course the solution
was cells
the idea was this a given area would be
split up into a pattern of hexagons at
the center of each of those hexagons was
a cell site these are generally thought
of as cell towers but that's a misnomer
since cell sites can be located on
buildings inside church steeples at the
tops of mountains or really anywhere
that's elevated relative to the typical
user fundamentally these cell sites just
send and receive radio signals to and
from cell phones which is a fairly
simple process
then they need a way to plug into the
wired communication network to convey
data over longer distances often this is
accomplished through physical fiber
optic cables but especially in more
rural areas that's not always practical
if one put a cell site on the top of a
mountain for example it would likely
have to operate completely off-grid
powered by solar or a generator and it
also couldn't physically plug into the
wire communication network due to its
isolation therefore these more remote
cell sites use microwave transmitters
now tiny microwaves thanks to their
extremely rapid frequency are incredibly
efficient at moving huge amounts of data
fast the most advanced systems have
reached over 100 gigabits per second but
they're not very resilient one needs a
direct line of sight between the
transmitter and receiver to accurately
transmit which prevents microwaves used
for portable cell phones however for
fixed cell sites this is possible so
many are set up with microwave
transmission systems that relay signal
to the closest site with a physical link
to the wired communication network with
both a wired and wireless option cell
sites can be located nearly anywhere
which is important because their
location absolutely matters
centering their hexagon the signal from
each of these sites must reach far
enough that there is some overlap
between the cells that way if a cell
phone is being used on the move the call
can be seamlessly passed from one cell
site to the next with no drop off in
signal and the network can be expanded
far beyond the reach of one transmitter
however the system starts to seem less
ingenious once you do the math
originally only 832 different
frequencies were allocated for use by
cell phones there are a lot of different
uses for the radio spectrum so
regulatory bodies like the american fcc
british ofcom or german b nets uh can
only allocate so many frequencies for
different industries and spectrum
allocation is crucial so that two users
don't try to use the same frequency or
to render both of their uses useless
so of those 832 frequencies 42 were used
by the cell network for its own back-end
internal communication that left 790 but
a call required both an outbound and
inbound frequency effectively meaning
there were only 395 call channels
however in order to prevent interference
no two bordering cells could use the
same frequency as each hexagon had six
neighbors that meant each cell could
only use one seventh of the available
channels
so each cell had 56 channels meaning 56
users within each cell could make a call
at a given time this initially worked
fine but then cell phones got popular to
keep up with demand cell carriers needed
to find a way to do more with a single
frequency when the second generation of
mobile networks came along calls were no
longer transmitted as analog audio waves
rather they started to use those digital
signals encoded using phase and
amplitude the thing was this method was
more efficient meaning using a whole
channel to transmit a single voice
conversation was overkill one only
needed part of it of course the
difficulty was that voice conversations
happen in real time it's not like you
could compress an entire two-minute call
and send it at the end therefore cell
companies divided a given channel into
eight time slots these time slots would
rotate one after another in rapid
succession and a given phone would be
told to use say the third time slot so
each time that time slot came up it
would fire off its ones and zeros
quickly then wait for it to come around
again but because the data was
compressed into an efficient digital
signal the amount received during a time
slot would be enough to decode into
enough of the conversation to play until
the next time slot came up this system
meant that one channel could now be used
by eight phones simultaneously what was
56 channels now became 448
but
eventually as phones became ever more
commonplace this system of time division
multiple access became once again
not good enough
the next evolution was where things got
complicated but also fascinating it's
called code division multiple access
it's an ingenious way where multiple
phones can send and receive data on the
same channel truly simultaneously to
explain the incredibly simple version
let's say a first user wants to transmit
the binary sequence one one a second
user zero one and a third one zero now
each of these users would be allocated
what's called a spreading code zero one
zero one zero zero one one and zero zero
zero zero respectively for the first
user their first binary digit one would
be compared to each of the four digits
of their spreading code if the spread
code digit and the binary digit is the
same it will output a zero if it's
different it will output a one so for
user one the output sequence would be
one zero one zero one zero one zero the
process would repeat for user two which
output zero zero one one one one zero
zero and user three which outputs one
one one one zero zero zero zero next
these sequences are translated so that
zeros become positive ones and ones
become negative ones then each digit of
the three sequences of numbers are added
together that outputs the composite
sequence negative one one negative three
negative one negative one one one three
this composite sequence is what is then
transmitted using a single channel now
the exact details of this process are
not tremendously important but what is
is what happens next what happens next
is that this process is reversed so the
receiver of that composite sequence
would know each user's unique spreading
code the spreading code is also
translated so that zeros become positive
ones and ones become negative ones and
then the receiver multiplies the
composite sequence with this translated
spreading code for user one that outputs
negative one negative one negative three
one negative one negative one one
negative three now the first four digits
of this sequence which we know correlate
with the first digit of the data are
added together to get negative four
which is then divided by four to get
negative one the process repeats for the
second set of four to get negative one
now if we translate this back so that
negative ones become ones and positive
ones become zeros then we get the data
sequence one
one with just the composite sequence and
the unique spreading code this process
figured out what user one's unique data
sequence was if we repeat this entire
decoding process with user two spreading
code we get zero one its data sequence
and unsurprisingly it also works for
user three so with one composite signal
and three unique spreading codes we are
able to triple up the use of one channel
in practice this process works at a much
larger much more complex scale but it
uses these same mathematical principles
this fundamentally is how cell service
works
making a two-way radio work for one
person is simple making a two-way radio
work for everyone in the same area at
the same time
is difficult it's all about packing as
much data as possible into a single
transmission and then packing as many
transmissions as possible into a single
radio wave the aforementioned techniques
to accomplish these two goals are only
the tip of the iceberg many of the most
advanced networks have moved on to a
system called orthogonal frequency
division multiple access to pack even
more transmissions into a single
wavelength for example but they are
indicative of the process that got us to
today when we move from 3g to 4g and 4g
to 5 what's happening in the background
is incredibly smart people finding more
and more ingenious methods of
transmitting more data using the same
resources all so that we the end users
can browse twitter and watch youtube
just ever so slightly faster
now that this video is over i am
extremely excited to announce that in
just two weeks we'll be releasing our
first ever feature length documentary
it's called the colorado problem a river
in the red
never before have i been more surprised
that the story isn't covered more the
colorado river the river that
single-handedly supplies water for the
entire desert region of the american
southwest is becoming smaller and
smaller and smaller each year and the
reserves are almost gone put another way
in much of utah nevada arizona and
california people need more water than
they can get our documentary covers what
led to such a cataclysmic problem and
the harsh reality of the future for the
american southwest you'll be able to
watch it on either curiosity stream or
nebula when it releases on february 8th
but of course if you're not currently a
subscriber of either of those streaming
services the curiosity stream nebula
bundle deal available on sale now for
less than 15 a year at
curiositystudent.com wendover gets you
access to both curiosity stream has a
huge catalog of top quality non-fiction
shows and documentaries while nebula is
the streaming site founded by creators
including myself to act as the best home
to the stuff we make it features all our
normal videos early and ad-free
occasional exclusive behind the scenes
and companion videos as well as the big
budget nebula originals that many of you
know so well so make sure to block off
90 minutes on february 8th to watch the
colorado problem and if you haven't
already head to
curiositystream.comwendover or click the
button on screen to get both nebula and
curiosity stream for less than what you
pay for a month of the larger streaming
services and you'll be helping support
wendover and tons of other independent
creators while you're at it